[Music]
on this monday night ontario's
unrelenting coveted surge
we're not going to be able to stop it
the restrictions returning there as
other provinces try to figure out how to
prevent being overwhelmed by omicron the
curriculum on keeping covid out of
classrooms we need to pull out all the
stops why critics say provinces need to
follow the lesson plan already given to
them
secret legal deal unsealed why prince
andrew may not be able to escape a sex
assault trial
and the art of upcycling building a
little treasure out of a lot of trash
one man's creative mission to reduce
plastic waste
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
ontario is kicking off 2022 with more
closures and cancellations as the
province races to control the rapid
spread of the omicron variant premier
doug ford resisted imposing strict
measures before the holidays despite the
science advisory table recommending a
circuit breaker approach since then
ontario's covet 19 caseload has
skyrocketed and ford says the
restrictions are needed to prevent the
health care system from being pushed to
the brink new measures will come into
effect at midnight wednesday they
include at home learning for students
for the next two weeks canceling all
non-essential surgeries and shutting
down dining rooms gyms theaters museums
and other indoor venues for three weeks
premier ford says he fears the caseload
could explode even further without these
measures restriction-weary businesses
are feeling the pain while overloaded
health workers are nearing their
breaking points mike trolley has our top
story tonight
give this toronto pharmacy an a for
prioritizing teachers looking to get
booster shots and stay in class i think
it's very important because
it just takes one positive case to throw
many worlds up into people well upheaval
has officially arrived in ontario with
premier doug ford reluctantly announcing
the return of restrictions starting
wednesday most everything will either be
closed or face new capacity limits
schools will return to online learning
and restaurants will once again only
offer takeout we feel like a political
football we just we feel like it's the
we're the easiest target
and uh they feel they have to do
something so they close us down we look
at the data that work is available and
it doesn't seem like we're
the spread the problem according to
ontario's top health officials is that
omicron is spreading at a rate unseen at
any time during the pandemic we're not
going to be able to stop it we'll have
to blunt it as best we can the early
statistics suggest omicron is far less
dangerous for most people than the delta
variant only one percent of those
infected with omicron will end up in the
hospital and likely for days not weeks
but premier doug ford says by doing
nothing the sheer volume of cases will
overwhelm the health care system i was
told
that we could see hundreds of thousands
of cases let's be conservative let's say
a hundred thousand cases or two hundred
thousand that's a day
that's a thousand people
two thousand people showing up to
hospitals
uh that that that's not sustainable
complicating matters is the issue of
absenteeism which the government says is
as high as 30 percent through all
sectors of the economy we're beyond the
point of exhaustion i think that you
know there is despair amy varley is a
nurse who says it's not uncommon for her
to work 16-hour days i remember when i
worked and i'd go in and you know you
were two to three nurses short and that
was still a difficult shift we're seeing
six nurses short seven nurses short
i don't understand how we can be working
in a system where there's that many
nurses that aren't there to help provide
that care
hospitals are once again struggling to
keep up ontario is trying to prevent
them from breaking microleg global news
toronto
in just over two weeks we've gone from
thirty active cases to almost three
thousand active cases in our province at
this point the sheer number of cases is
overwhelming public health capacity for
case investigation
newfoundland and labrador's top doctor
says the province can no longer identify
every positive case and contact as it's
successfully done for the past two years
the objective now is to just slow the
spread of the omicron variant the
province will move to the second highest
level of its covid19 alert system at
midnight
officials there only have to look south
to nova scotia's rapid climb in cases
and new brunswick which is nearing 1 000
new cases per day a milestone the
province is expected to reach by the
middle of this week as ross lord
explains the atlantic provinces are
having to make some difficult decisions
to help protect health care
new year same pandemic with dimensions
that can be hard to put into context if
you had told me a year ago that we'd be
starting 2022
with a fourth wave
i simply wouldn't have believed you but
here we are
you've seen the numbers
how one day's record stands until it's
beaten by the next days with new covert
19 cases topping 500 a day and 3 000
active cases newfoundland and labrador
is imposing tighter restrictions on
gathering limits but the vast majority
of people infected do not need to be
hospitalized and the province is feeling
pressure to open up society and let the
virus run its course
better to limit transmission and spread
out the infections according to premier
andrew fury if everybody does get it
they can't all get it at once and it's
not just because of the beds in the
hospital it's about the human resource
capacity to deal with people in the
hospital
especially around
nurses physicians allied health
professionals who are isolating as well
in nova scotia there's a similar
delicate balance january will be a tough
month and i expect that the premier and
i will have some more hard decisions to
make one of those decisions should nova
scotia join other provinces that are
reducing the isolation period to five
days for double vaccinated people who've
been infected but have no symptoms or
should infected workers like nurses come
out of isolation and work if essential
services are in jeopardy the
controversial measure could make sense
according to this nova scotia licensed
practical nurse you wouldn't be able to
be in the break room with anybody else
unmasked you would have to eat you know
by yourself that sort of thing so i
think there's ways to get around it so
that we can have as maximum
amount of people at work as we actually
as we possibly could nova scotia's top
doctor says he'll have more to say about
isolation rules later this week in the
meantime vaccinations are accelerating
nova scotians age 30 and over are now
eligible for booster shots with 1700
people volunteering to administer the
doses ross lord global news
well the decision to close schools and
return to remote learning in ontario and
quebec is being met with a lot of
anxiety and frustration omicron is
forcing officials to focus on how to
minimize kovid's spread in schools as
jamie morocco explains experts say the
toolkit for keeping children healthy is
available we just need to use it
this daily outing around their toronto
neighborhood might become the norm for
sarah jackson and her family over the
next couple of weeks as her kids return
to online learning you know it's a lot
to
to figure out time and time again
omicron's wildfire increase in cases has
pushed ontario and quebec to return to
remote schooling for a couple weeks at
least while bc and alberta have pushed
back post-holiday start dates i
certainly
recognize it's very very difficult for
parents and for students to manage that
kind of thing
but
we're kind of in a crisis mode right now
so i think we need to pull out all the
stops some public health experts agree
that means pulling kids out of class
others worry advice to avoid this
scenario again has fallen on deaf ears
over the last year
take enhancing ventilation and
filtration
what i feel very confident in saying is
that we're probably underpowered in a
lot of classrooms
six air changes every 60 minutes is best
and a single hepa filter won't cut it
many schools don't have the funding to
do major upgrades and if they do it can
take time
in the short term there's masking
experts say it's time to ditch the
cotton face cover and upgrade to a
surgical mask at the very least and
while some are even advocating for n95s
in schools there's debate among
infectious disease specialists it's it's
a little bit more difficult to sort of
imply that kind of reach out to the
community and it's really important to
understand n95 mass are much more
expensive in ontario the association
advocating for its english language
public schools wants the province to
pick up the tab and is also hoping to
see the covet 19 vaccine become
mandatory for all students over age five
across canada just over 1 percent of
kids 5 to 11 have received their double
dose so far but we still do have a lot
of families that haven't yet made the
decision to get their child vaccinated
and that's going to set us back a little
bit until there's an increase in uptake
public health experts are again calling
for smaller class sizes jackson's
partner sammy agrees but isn't hopeful
some of this stuff like you can't change
overnight meantime the most obvious
piece of advice to keep kids coveted
free falls on parents like him in an
omicron era at the first sign of
sniffles stay home jamie morocco global
news toronto
an ontario court has awarded 107 million
dollars in compensation to six families
whose loved ones were killed in the
downing of a passenger jet over iran
iran's military fired two missiles at
ukrainian airlines flight 752 moments
after it took off from tehran's airport
two years ago this week killing
everybody on board 55 canadians and 30
permanent residents were among the dead
lawyers for the six families say they'll
look to seize iranian assets in canada
and internationally to pay for the
compensation
in action to the insurrection coming up
the growing claims former u.s president
trump refused to stop the riots
plus post-christmas chaos the winter
wallop wreaking havoc on millions of
americans
and from relevant to relic why those
classic blackberries are turning into
bricks
[Applause]
tonight more than 20 million americans
from georgia to massachusetts are being
pummeled by a powerful winter storm
causing travel chaos and disruptions at
airports more than three thousand
flights have been canceled 5400 more
delayed and the numbers are expected to
soar as more americans scramble to get
home after the holidays at the height of
the storm more than 700 thousand
customers lost power in washington alone
up to 25 centimeters of snow is expected
before the storm ends
this thursday marks one year since the
attack on the u.s capital an act of
political violence aimed at overturning
the results of the 2020 election
hundreds of people now face criminal
charges but there are still unanswered
questions about the role former
president donald trump played in
inciting and directing the mob americans
are divided over what happened but as
jackson proskow reports there is
mounting evidence trump stood by as the
attack unfolded
nearly one year after the attack on
american democracy
there are fresh claims that former
president donald trump sat idly by as
his supporters stormed the u.s capitol
building the committee has first-hand
testimony that
president trump was sitting in the
dining room next to the oval office
watching on television as the capitol
was assaulted as the violence
occurred
we know that that is clearly a supreme
dereliction of duty republican liz
chaney who sits on the committee
investigating january 6 revealed that
trump was repeatedly pressured to
intervene by republican house leader
kevin mccarthy and by trump's daughter
ivanka we have first-hand testimony that
his daughter ivanka
went in at least twice
to ask him to please stop this violence
as the investigation digs deeper into
trump's actions and inaction that day
americans remain deeply divided over
what exactly happened as rioters
breached the capitol building during the
certification of joe biden's victory
85 percent of democrats consider it an
insurrection compared to just 21 percent
of republicans while 56 percent of
republicans believe january 6 was about
defending freedom it means that we are
very very divided in this nation among
things just as simple as law and order
and the results of elections the divide
extends to how one of the darkest days
in modern american history will be
commemorated on thursday president joe
biden will address the nation from the
capitol as lawmakers share first-hand
accounts of what they experienced during
the siege while trump will hold his own
press conference where he's likely to
rehash his infamous lie about a stolen
election he's going to try to say that
the real insurrection was on november
3rd on election day and the big lie is
that he lost and that it was stolen from
him it all previews a worrying year to
come with contentious midterm elections
set for the fall against the backdrop of
the ongoing investigation into january
sixth the committee may still issue
subpoenas for trump criminal charges
against the former president remain a
possibility too
as divided as americans are over the
events of january 6 they are united in
their worry about the future of the
country one recent poll found that 62
percent of americans fear violence over
the outcome of future presidential
elections
jackson prosko global news washington
firefighters in south africa battled a
stubborn flare-up at the country's
parliament today crews were back at it
trying to get the upper hand on a
devastating fire that was believed to be
under control officials had warned of
flare-ups because of all the carpets and
wood floors in the building on sunday
the roof of the old wing which dates
back to 1884 partially collapsed the
building is also home to thousands of
historic books photos and works of art a
49 year old man has been charged with
arson and theft
still ahead could an old deal help
shield prince andrew from a civil
[Music]
lawsuit a newly unsealed deal could
possibly impact a lawsuit against prince
andrew the 2009 legal settlement between
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
and the woman accusing prince andrew of
forcing her into sex as a teenager has
been made public in it epstein agrees to
pay virginia due for a half a million
dollars if she agrees not to sue him or
anyone as redmond shannon reports a
judge will hear arguments tomorrow on
whether due phrase civil case can
proceed
despite this now infamous picture prince
andrew has always maintained his
innocence
i have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady his accuser virginia dufrey
says the duke of york forced her into
sex three times when she was under 18.
she says she was trafficked by the
prince's friends convicted sex offenders
jeffrey epstein and epstein's girlfriend
gelaine maxwell in 2019 epstein died in
prison last week maxwell was convicted
of sex trafficking young girls we're
told constantly you know these people
will never go to jail they're too
powerful they're too rich this is not
the end this is just the beginning
andrew has not been accused of any
criminal wrongdoing his lawyers will
argue before a judge tuesday that
epstein's 2009 settlement with dufres
shields the prince from her civil
lawsuit in the newly published document
epstein agreed to pay you for 500 000
u.s dollars if she agreed not to sue any
other person or entity who could have
been included as a potential defendant
from all manner of legal action that is
just so vague and bizarre to me lawyer
lisa bloom represented eight of
epstein's victims she says the judge
should allow duprey's case against
andrew to proceed despite the epstein
deal i think it would be wrong and a
violation of essential principles of
contract law to have prince andrew
released because he's not mentioned by
name anywhere in the agreement even if
andrew's lawyers succeed royal watchers
think the damage is done i think
regardless of what happens in the next
couple of days in the states prince
andrew's career as a working royal is
sadly over
i think he's finished his reputation is
in such tatters that i really don't
think he can come back from this if the
case does go ahead it's not expected to
begin until september redmond shannon
global news london
hong kong's free press suffered another
blow today with the online site citizen
news announcing it is shutting down the
publication says the decision was made
over the safety of its reporters after
police raided pro-democracy outlet stan
news last month arresting staff members
on sedition charges this is the third
outlet to shutter in recent months in
hong kong press freedoms in hong kong
have been deteriorating since beijing
introduced a sweeping national security
law in 2020
starting tomorrow many blackberry mobile
phones will stop reliably working the
company has decommissioned several of
its services devices using old software
through wi-fi connections could now have
trouble making phone calls sending text
messages and accessing 9-1-1 the change
will not impact phones running on
android software blackberry first
announced it would end some services in
2020 as part of its transition towards a
software company
turning junk into gems next the bc man
giving plastic an artsy new purpose
a new brunswick wildlife shelter is
starting off 2022 with a rare rescue it
took in a black vulture for the first
time in a facebook post the atlantic
wildlife institute says the bird was
found new year's day in moncton unable
to fly it has a severe eye injury black
vultures are more common in warmer
climates like south america but
sightings in the maritimes have risen in
recent years
the city of vancouver is doing its part
to help keep plastic bags out of
landfills on january 1st vancouver
became the latest canadian city to ban
single-use plastic bags it's a dramatic
shift for some but for one bc man it's
just second nature he's been doing his
part to keep them out of the trash for
decades and all he needs is an artistic
touch jay durant explains
for the past year roger brenneckmeyer
has been turning people's trash into
someone else's treasure taking plastic
bags and overwrap and creating beautiful
pieces of art
so this amount of plastic turns into
that this environmentally conscious
career is decades in the making in the
late 80s roger helped his high school
launch its first recycling program he
ended up working in corporate
communications printing reports and
brochures that got him thinking about
damage to the forests and then something
clicked i kind of had a jerry maguire
moment this moment will be the moment of
something real
and fun
and i said you know what i'm actually
part of a problem here not part of the
solution
to date roger figures he saved about 150
000 plastic bags from the landfill this
installation at a senior's home in
richmond used about 18 thousand bags
they get to go down to breakfast every
morning and look up and see a beautiful
wisteria tree knowing that their trash
is actually part of that
that beautiful mosaic
now he's working on a new technique to
turn bigger ocean plastics like fishing
nets and crab baskets into art hoping to
inspire others to look at this type of
business idea
maybe they don't do art but maybe they
create uh
plates or stools or or whatnot just as
long as we are taking something that is
deemed landfill and transforming it into
something that is beautiful that is
useful
anyone ordering a piece can hand over
their own plastic bags if not roger
still has so much to get through
we can actually create new product
out of something that is going straight
to the to the garbage can
you know building a little treasure out
of a lot of trash
jay durant global news
beautiful in more ways than one and that
is global national for this monday night
i'm nitu garcia tonight's your canada is
the village of caroline alberta there
are beautiful spots all over canada
please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a great night